In my latest urinalysis lab, it showed a clarity as
KZ, and a trace amount of protein in my urinalysis lab.
amorphous crystals, which were abnormal, my GP call to ask
if I have a history of kidney stones, which I don't.
The last time I had an abnormal neuro-religion,
billinated, reading, but this was normal now.
I'm wondering if some supplement I'm taking is causing some weird
uA results, which I've never had before.
I'd have to look at your supplement.
If you were taking, unless you change to a different supplement,
some new supplement, if there was a supplement that you were taking
that was causing amorphous crystals, you'd think they would have been causing amorphous crystals.
The whole time you were taking the supplement, and now they just all of a sudden started causing that.
Unless it's something new that you're taking, I don't think it's that.
When you have amorphous crystals in a uA, a trace amount of protein in a uA,
you're also going to look at, are you dehydrated, but you have an increased
concentration of your urine, so these things are showing.
I don't know, let me do some research on that.
Kidney stones can be caused from oxalates.
So if you happen to be eating a lot of oxalates, we used to see this.
We did more uAs in people in office during times where they're eating a lot of rhubarb
and things that have a lot of oxalates in them with different times in the season.
You'd see some different changes.
I'd have to look at your genetics. I think we did you genetics of this person who asked this question to see if you have any genetic defects on your oxalate genes that.
The expulsion of those, so I would have to.
I'd have to do some investigation on your genes to to see if that's an issue too.
But I will look, I'll try to look at your supplement list and let me know if there's anything you added or changed recently between uA and LSSS.